this video was made possible by
Squarespace build your website for 10%
off at squarespace.com slash Wendover
it's 4 a.m. on a mid-august morning in
the northern california wilderness
during a brief overnight storm lightning
strikes the top of a hill ignites some
dry underbrush and starts a wildfire it
isn't until 6 a.m. as the Sun rises that
someone notices the fire
a hiker camping on an overlooking Hill
as soon as the hikers 911 received by
the emergency dispatch center they
contact Cal Fire the agency responsible
for wildfire protection and management
in California by 6:30 they call the
Redding california-based smokejumpers
they are one of the most elite
firefighting squads in the United States
there are only 400 smoke jumpers in the
US and 40 of those are based here in
Redding California they're essentially
the Rapid Response Team for wildfires
within 15 minutes of receiving the call
these monk jumpers are in their plane
and taking off it takes just 20 minutes
to fly the 50 miles to the fire site
where they find a suitable tree free
landing spot jump deploy their
parachutes and land the plane then
circles back to parachute down boxes of
equipment smoke jumpers carry with them
enough supplies to last 72 hours
completely self supported food water
shelter safety equipment and
firefighting tools they follow the
ridgeline and make their way to the fire
now this is a small team and they need
to decide how to prioritize what they do
with the fire already having grown to 15
acres the team knows they're unlikely to
stop it on their own backups are already
on the way so their priority is to slow
it down as much as possible there are
four major factors that affect how fast
a fire moves how much fuel there is how
wet the fuel is the wind direction and
the slope the two factors that the team
can immediately gauge that affect where
the fire will move fastest or the wind
direction and slope in this case the
wind is coming from the north and they
know that to the southwest is an upward
slope fire moves faster uphill than it
does downhill since the fire burns
upwards so these smoke jumpers know that
this is likely the fires fastest moving
front while trees do burn the primary
source of fuel that a wildfire uses to
move is the dry brush and Deadwood on
the forest floor so the biggest
technique used to stop forest fires is
to create what's called a fire line
these are essentially a gap where they
remove all fuel plants both dead and
alive so that there's nothing for the
fire to continue burning the
smokejumpers use a mix of chainsaws and
other hand tools to do this work but
sometimes fire lines are pre-built in
this case there's a road at the top of
the uphill section which will help slow
or stop the fire so they can direct
their efforts elsewhere they use the
road as their anchor point a cleared
section that the fire likely won't cross
where they start building their fire
lines so the fire can't outflank them
throughout this construction process the
smokejumpers need to be sure that they
can escape in case the wind shift or the
fire picks up speed wildfires can move
exceptionally fast up to seven miles per
hour in forest which is faster than
humans are often able to make their way
through tens trees in grasslands fires
can move up to 14 miles per hour so
firefighters have to be extra cautious
for this reason firefighters rarely put
themselves directly in front of the
fires moving front they'll either be far
ahead or to the side in the case of this
fire as they're building this first fire
line they're close to a road which acts
as an easy exit point but just in case
all smoke jumpers carry fire shelters
these compact lightweight shelters won't
survive direct flames for too long but
they do greatly increase a firefighters
chance of survival in case they can't
escape the path of a fire after a little
over an hour of work the smokejumpers
completes a continuous fire line from
the road to a stream streams while less
secure than roads also helps stop or
slow down a fire by acting as a fire
line to the southeast of the fire
there's also a small road that connects
to another stream meaning there are at
least rudimentary fire lines on three
sides of the fire it's at this time when
backups arrive by Road
the added manpower allows for much
faster action the immediate focus goes
to strengthening the southeastern fire
line currently just a stream at closest
the fire is less than 100 feet from the
stream and the stream is itself in a
valley so it's too risky to work
directly behind the stream there's just
no good escape route so the new arrivals
get to work on a redundant fire line 100
feet behind the stream by 10 a.m. the
fire has further grown and the team
knows that the worst is still to come
fire spreads most rapidly between 10
a.m. and sunset due to the daytime heat
and wind by 11 a.m. the fire has reached
the road and part of the fire line which
means that some of
those who are building the fire line are
reallocated to make sure that the fire
line holds as ding wishing any flames
that may jump the road by noon the fire
lines are holding and all the fire size
is growing it's at a manageable pace so
there's reasonable hope that it can be
suppressed before expanding to an
uncontrollable size at 1:00 p.m. though
conditions change the wind starts
blowing harder towards the southwest and
as trees burn on the north side of the
road the wind pushes embers over the
road which ignite underbrush on the
other side and now the entire focus of
the firefighting effort change you see
the point of fighting wildfires is not
actually to put them out is to control
them while the number of wildfires has
increased due to humans they're actually
a very natural phenomenon what's making
wildfires worse is humans stopping them
many forests survive wildfire through
trees having heat-resistant bark and
other evolutionary adaptations these
fire resistant forests relied on having
wildfires at a consistent interval every
few decades to clear out the forest
floor of dead plants and to kill
invasive species nowadays though as
humans suppress fires a force might only
see a wildfire every 50 years instead of
25 for example meaning that there's
twice as much fuel and so the fire burns
faster larger and more intensely it was
only until recent years at the research
revealing this was widely accepted so
the goals of firefighting shifted from
stopping wildfires completely to
controlling them in some places being a
fire fighter actually means starting
fires fire management agencies will
conduct controlled burns in order to
reduce the risk of an uncontrollable
fire and to increase the health of a
forest while forests can survive
wildfires humans cannot so most agencies
will let fires burn in a controlled
fashion up until the moment they risk
damaging property or threatening human
life this fire that jumped the road just
did exactly that at the bottom of this
slope is a town and the fire is now
headed in that direction with no
pre-existing features to stop it that
means that all measures must be taken to
aggressively stop the fires expansion to
the west that means it's time to bring
out the big guns it's time to attack the
fire from above planes and helicopters
are some of the most effective tools
used to fight wildfires they can quickly
and accurately drop huge amounts of
water or
fire-retardant the decision to use
aerial firefighting does not come
lightly as it's both hugely expensive
and using an aircraft on one fire means
it can't be used on another their use
needs to be prioritized for the most
dangerous fires there's also a decision
to be made on what the aircraft is going
to drop water or flame retardant water
is cheap and with some aircraft designs
can be reloaded near the fire without
landing at an airport water is only
effective at extinguishing flames though
flame retardant on the other hand can be
used to stop flames from starting it can
essentially create a fire line ahead of
the fire spread as it will stop a line
of forest from burning the main issues
though are that flame retardant can only
be loaded at an airport and it's a very
expensive a gallon of FOSS check the
most commonly used brand of flame
retardant costs $3 that's about the same
as a gallon of milk at the grocery store
but these aircraft use thousands of
gallons of it for each drop the world's
largest firefighting aircraft the 747
super tanker for example carries 19
thousand six hundred gallons of flame
retardant meaning that what it uses in
one drop costs nearly sixty thousand
dollars of course there's a reason
agencies hire this plane it creates a
three-mile long fire line almost
instantly but it comes at a steep price
for this fire using such an expensive
tool would be overkill in this case
they'll use a helicopter with a bucket
attached the bucket is filled with water
from a nearby lake and then the
helicopter flies over to the fire and
drops it with only five miles to the
lake the helicopter is able to make a
drop about every five to ten minutes and
well it works on stopping the spread on
one side hand crews work on building a
fire line on the other the area that the
helicopter extinguishes essentially acts
as its own fire line as fire can't burn
which already burned this work continues
for the next few hours it's vital not to
let anything to the southwest of the
road burn out of control by 4:00 p.m.
the outbreak is managed and attention
can be directed back to the largest
section of the fire as the afternoon
wears on some crews get back to
lengthening the eastern fire line others
begin constructing a Western fire line
and the helicopter works on slowing the
advancement to the north by the time the
Sun begins to set around 8 all sides of
the fire have at least some element of
control so that during the night and in
the
coming days the fire can continue to
burn in a controlled fashion until
there's nothing left to burn this
mission was a success but the reality is
that this is not a real fire real fires
rarely end this well real fires don't
act so predictably because real fires
can't be predicted real fires are a
menace that can grow to the size of
small countries and can burn for months
during summer and fall there are often
more than 100 large forest fires burning
around the u.s. at any given time and
thousands more around the world
no firefighting effort is exactly like
another but these are the primary
techniques used by those who work every
day to protect life and property from
one of nature's most dangerous
phenomenons whether you're fighting
forest fires or running a business the
tools you use are crucially important in
both cases they directly affect how well
you do your job and while chainsaws axes
and shovels are some of the most
important tools in firefighting
Squarespace is one of the most important
tools for running a business that's
because having a Squarespace website
helps you be found on the internet and
presents you or what you do in the best
way possible
there are beautiful designer templates
and customizable website builder make it
easy to make something that looks and
functions great you can easily run blog
a portfolio site an online store or
really any other type of website wit
Squarespace and well it's all super
simple
they have award-winning 24/7 customer
support to help you the best news is
that you can build your website for 10%
off by going to Squarespace comm /
Wendover and you'll be supporting the
show while you're at it